all right Mike Dowd Mike you you were
one of my favorite storytellers that
I've had on my channel your first video
was a magnificent
thank example of what I look for on my
channel thanks one of my favorites maybe
maybe my all-time favorite
um
but we didn't really get into the
conversation you just told your story
and that was basically it last time
right and there's a lot of questions I
would love to ask so you're back and we
can do that
um
you know you you did some you were a
corrupt cop in New York City this is the
80s well so I started in 82 by the time
I was corrupted in 84 five-ish like that
so till 92.
and uh
it was pretty bad right so the city was
bad and and as an outgrowth of that I
adapted to the to my to my environment
in a in a way that was anti-social
really right yeah but but you have to
you know factor in there's some other
factors that affected that what you were
paid at the time was what right so my
salary at the time when I signed the
police academy was 17 000 a year and
when I graduated the police academy it
was like eighteen five and by the time I
was actually a seasoned quote-unquote
veteran cop with like two or three years
experience my salary was probably
twenty four thousand dollars a year wow
it seems like cops firemen School
teachers are all like just terribly
underpaid
yeah it's unfortunate because I mean
that's the under underbelly of our
society that keeps that keeps us
floating from day to day between
educating our children keeping the
streets safe and keeping people from
dying you know yeah no I mean there's I
mean if there was ever a job that should
be paid well you'd think it'd be a cop
yeah yeah you know the unfortunate thing
is we take those jobs knowing that
they're not uh well-paying jobs uh but
we find some sort of altruistic value in
them but as it turns out it gets it gets
um how would you say it gets minimized
quite quickly your purpose
because because it's a system Mark and
like any governmental system
there's less appreciation and more
requirements as as you go you get you
get deeper into them and is there like
on the police force was there like this
General consensus that you guys are
underappreciated
economy here like because it's a
wonderfully res at the time billiona
police officer was fairly well respected
so it was you were considered a
professional so you you you're as you
were a blue collar but you were
considered a professional so it had a
little
um it had a little uh a way of raising
you above Society but you actually were
paid less than most people in society so
it it came with it came with some pride
unfortunate thing is
you didn't really feel that you were
um appreciated
and then all of a sudden an opportunity
to make real serious money comes along
and
and get away and probably getting so if
you remember the 75 documentary in the
documentary itself there's a a a
close-up of the girl
um
Kenny's urell's wife who passed and she
goes money feels good
so money feels good and
yeah so I think appreciation and money
could go hand in hand you know if if
someone does a good job at your house
and they're underpaid they really don't
appreciate or feel you feel the
appreciation what a painter what a
wonderful job he leaves the house he
still can't pay for gas in his car
that's you know one of the things I I
believe and I've been this way with
employees people that worked with me but
like let's let's take an artist but you
can call a police officer an artist or a
fireman or a doctor or a lawyer or
anything
when that person feels that they are
really appreciated
they're going to give their all
when they feel underappreciated
they're just not going to give their all
yeah yes and the quality diminishes yeah
and what you want are people working for
you who really are into really yeah yeah
so and in the police world you get that
where you get guys that are sloppy and
their approach that don't take the job
serious in the fact that while there may
be something that they should handle in
a more professional manner because
they're not appreciated listen it's not
right right we know this but that's what
happens there is human nature involved
in humans
that
that's why it's Human Nature
I mean so so you you went from being
a normal citizen to and all of a sudden
you're you become a prisoner you're
you're in prison you're a convict
and you get out eventually how many
years did you do so I was sentenced so
people don't know this and let me just
give you a little approach so when I was
arrested by the feds in 1992 when I
walked in the door I was facing life in
prison
and if people don't understand what that
feels like
when they close the door I mean the
first night
I was in what they call isolation
segregation the whole when I closed the
door I mean the first night I looked at
my surroundings which was like nine well
maybe it was 12
by seven wide it's cold as hell and I
said this is my life for the rest of it
like that's the first day
and I mean if you think about that
audience for a moment and people I know
you have a very wide audience I know
that they there's people in that
audience that are listening that know
that moment
and then to work your way out of that
we've only did a 14-year federal prison
sentence
which came down to 12 years five months
and 20 something days I can't give you
the hours but so
so right it's a blessing right think
about it
I was blessed I walked in a prison
facing life and I came out 12 and a half
years later and part of the thing that
you and I want to discuss a little bit I
believe is that after doing that time
I'm supposed to be welcome back into
society
what happened
well it's not it doesn't work that way I
found out and I'm sure many people in
your audience have felt that as well
um
so I ended up trying to get a job
first of all you're on Pro I was on
supervised release for five years
Now remind you I came out
really first of all I was fearful I
wanted to go back so I don't want to
diminish that the first
30 days I wanted to go back to prison
did you want to go back I wanted to go
back to prison
um I stood in the shower in my mother's
home I don't know if I had told this
story to you guys I slept in the shower
in my mother's home my first shower in
Freedom
and as the shower was hit just be just
before maybe because people checked me
just before I got in the shower I looked
out the window and I saw my brother's
two children
and I didn't know their names
and I think about that for a moment you
have a brother one of my seven siblings
or six siblings seven of us and he's got
two boys and they're not infants they're
like young boys and I don't even know
their names
and I step into the shower and the what
has hitting me from the shower and the
tears just open up for the first time in
my life since this incarceration I was
able to freely let out all
and I don't even know what it is and
maybe there's somebody out there that
can help me with I don't know what I was
letting out
because it was sorrow it was loss It Was
Fear it was every emotion that a person
can go through that they gave up
and as I was recollecting my thoughts I
mean I was exasperated I was leaning
against a wall in the shower and the
tears were making me wetter than the
water that's how severe it was
and I was just trying to catch gather my
thoughts and calm down because I'm in a
home with my parents now and they
haven't seen me outside of prison in 12
and a half years plus the 10 years prior
that I left their home right
and or whenever the numbers were at this
point
and uh and I'm trying to collect my
thoughts why am I so emotionally
brought the fraught but at this point
and it came to me that I didn't know
what I was going to do with the rest of
my life
like I don't even know these children's
name next door I really don't know my
own kids
two boys one that lives out here and one
that lives in Long Island
two grand four grandkids I have now
and I don't even know uh what am I going
to do how am I going to matriculate
through society as a guy that used to be
a police officer that finishes Federal
sentence and I have no really Hands-On
skills I'm a labor guy I can fix this I
can lift that I can move I can move I
can drive so I have some functionality
to earn a living but I don't see it as a
very fruitful prospectful future and
I end up really just want to go back to
prison so that's the moment that I
wanted to go back to prison and and now
I needed to recollect my thoughts
because I was around my parents for the
first time in Freedom and I didn't want
them to
I didn't want them to smell the fear
you know so I finished collecting my
thoughts I took the shower I calmed down
I took a moment to calm down so it's one
of the things about prison you learn is
to slow down
so I slowed down I thought things
through and I said what I'm gonna do is
the best I can do each day
so
I I started to rebuild the life
and part of the things that get thrown
at guys that do time and come out is
this a gap in their life so think about
it I was a police officer at 21 years
old
at 43 years old 44 years old I now have
to fill out an application for a job
what do I put NYPD prison I mean it's
like not a good position to be in
and
it led to quite a difficult time in fact
so I ended up becoming what you would
call a local uh I was your local
handyman okay I did a lot of work my
brother was involved in some
construction so and I did fairly well
financially I did okay
um but it wasn't a life's dream to be
swinging Hammers and banging on nails
for the next 30 40 years
and I wasn't that good at it okay I was
okay but but I could make a living but I
wasn't I didn't want to be the lead guy
on the job okay and uh so that was the
life I was faced with and it was I was
very full of I want to say fear because
of
um
what am I going to do in my 40s now so
now I'm 62. but in my 40s
I'm not a young man anymore starting out
like I just graduated college or high
school and I'm going to start a 30-year
career in a union job so it was a very
difficult position to be in however I
end up back in the union job
and here's the here's here's where it
flips Mark and this is what upsets me I
end up going to school spending for
trade school my own money no student
loan repayment program my own money I
spend it and I get to I get the trade
I'm looking for which was operating
engineer which I was a liced I'm
licensed today to run the big chillers
in buildings and plants and it's quite a
license to get it's significant and it's
probably today 150 200 000 a year job
so I land a job at a hospital by my home
and uh I'm just putting out the South
folks and anybody in your audience many
people will know South Oaks because it's
a rehab center
and
one of the bonuses to getting this job
was that it was in a rehab center and
being I had this uh passed they would be
easily willing to accept that so when I
filled out the application I got
promoted into this job they were like no
problem we understand this is a rehab
place everybody's on the second trip
around here great
then the documentary shows up
and
in the beginning it was received okay
but eventually after after a while
um HBO or Showtime picked it up and when
they picked it up it went global
and now the eyes are starting to look at
this hospital that this individual
Michael Dowd Works in
and then the phone starts ringing and
all I can tell you is I get called in
one day and
to the office right now in the hospital
I worked in if anybody knows about it
and your audience will because you have
a best audience
it's about a mile long from where I was
to where I had to go report so on my way
there I'm saying to myself do I need a
lawyer I was like a joke in my head
right
so I'm reporting to the office I sit
down and I look in the room and I look
at these two guys one's my direct
supervisor and one's my Superior
supervisor oh good supervisors right
so
they look at me and I go
what's up do I need a lawyer like I just
typical down statement what do I need a
lawyer and they look at me and they sort
of put their head down and they go
no but we have to suspend you I and I've
like you guys are joking right I said
did I do something wrong I don't know
you you work my my work something wrong
no but you know you're walking around
here talking about maybe doing a book or
a movie
as a result of this 7-5 documentary
so you're promoting your own personal
business while at work so we're gonna
have to suspend you for promoting your
personal business at work I said wait a
minute
because you know I'm not stupid and I'm
all quiet wait a minute so your
employees my co-workers
are asking me questions about my life
and by answering them
I'm going to lose my job will be
suspended at least
well we have to do it
and I looked at the both of them and I
said to you someone made a phone call to
you
and
they said that their family or their
life is in danger because I'm here and
that there might be retribution
sought against me because I was a police
officer and quote unquote shook down
drug dealers this is this conversation
went and they looked at me and they went
like this no
that's what they did I said okay turn
around I left well on the way out there
do I realize that I actually got injured
today so I took I turned it back around
and I went back and see if you don't I
don't know you get my whole right side
is is mangled people don't know this but
anyway so I ended up taking a walk for
being injured at work that day and we
ended up in a long battle with them so
there was a settlement made at some
point but
but not
I made a phone call
so that goes back to the subject that
was that you and I approached earlier
slightly that we said you know um
when does it end
when does the retribution for your being
a convict or committing a crime when
does it end
you know I mean I'm I'm a little bit of
numbers guy and anybody that knows me in
your channel I'm sure they know me by
now I'm a numbers guy I do the math real
quick 10 15 years I lost 150 000 out of
your job ten years is 1.5 million right
so
I've given up a lot of money to do that
documentary you know and then I've of
course if I speak to the guys and then
let it go yeah hang in there kid yeah
they really they don't care about you
much
so this is the life I've had to live and
and what that brings me back to the
beginning of the question when does it
end why do I have to continually
be pigeonholed and you're a bad guy
you're always been a bad guy you've
never done anything good I mean I'm
trying I'm I'm human I'm I'm flawed
you're walking a straight line now I
walk a straight line now listen there
are days when I was a little more
crooked on some of the lines but the
fact is this
I do the best I can to be a better human
every day
I mean
you you and I have a little bit of a
relationship Mark and in a good way you
know and
I I think that I'm direct and honest
absolutely and I think that's all we can
want from the guy next to us to be
direct and be honest and and and to
carry your weight
and I think I do all that and so I try
to portray that in everything I do
and I'm flawed we're all flawed let me
ask you a question do you think
that a man or a woman person who has
made a huge mistake like you did
and paid a price for it and
dealt with it however you deal with your
mistakes
and then come out the other side
is a more well-rounded
evolved person than one who has never
done anything wrong I love this question
and you know why because that's what I
make my living on today and I use that
term loosely
uh my phone and you've you've seen it
while I'm here go off several times not
during the interview but prior my phone
doesn't stop and be why because people
respect and appreciate my experience now
because
the more like you know a guy can start
10 businesses eight or nine of them
probably will fail but by the time the
tenth one succeeds he's had all the
experiences and pitfalls in life so
that's just probably gonna be a damn
good business the one that succeeds and
so I fell down a few times in life and
people seem to find that
attractive or alluring but they I mean
and I use this example and I may have
said it on your show so I don't want to
sound repetitive but I have cops reach
out to me and civilians today not just
cops now civilians as well that have
either trouble in their life
they're running into trouble in their
life or they don't know where to go or
what to do and I I think I've become
quite a decent um sounding board number
one because people sometimes just and
you notice some people sometimes people
just want to be listened to they just
want to they want to be able to say it
and they don't necessarily want you to
solve it so sometimes what I'll do is
I'll listen and I'll say well do you
want me to help you by giving you some
of my experiences and how they turned
out otherwise because you're going to do
what you're going to do but if I tell
you the path I took and what I did at
this moment you know did I go to AAA
meetings
did I did I call a drug dealer what what
did I do at this moment of my life if I
share that with you one you don't have
to take it but two I'm giving of myself
and like we spoke when I came in here
about the dollar thing when I've told
you about before
like that 62 years of experience
it might not be a good experience but
there's 62 years that I every word that
we utter and everything we do for
somebody else it comes with that time
invested you know Mark you do some good
things I know you do you've done it the
past and myself I try
do comes from all of that hard work that
people don't see what came before this
you know but to put this camera on me
and to set this thing up
people just can't do this they think
they can and make it look easy they make
it well you make it look easy but that
because the guy that comes in your house
and paints your house in two hours he's
been doing it for 40 years that's why
you pay him as much as you pay the guide
it takes three days
because his experience and his wisdom
got him through your house in two hours
with other guys still there three days
later they may do the same quality job
but the fact is that this guy knows
we I those of us who experience know
the pitfalls I I Mentor a lot of guys on
um
today I'd say at oxy right and oxy's
very close to Fentanyl and you know a
friend of ours who lost his daughter
John lost his daughter and I'm sure you
know many people that lost their people
in Fentanyl and I keep telling my buddy
you gotta understand something it's it
it's all good till it's not and then
it's too late
I'm not a preacher I just I just point
it out
and uh so
right now I'm actually taking a guy
through fentanyl withdrawals not
fentanyl I'm sorry gotta use the wrong
term oxy withdrawals I mean I spend a
thousand dollars a day on after cotton
that's 30 000 a month
I mean so
I do what I can each day Mark and uh
I just don't like being attacked Mark
okay I don't like being attacked and you
and I have discussed this before and we
we thought we'd discussed it a little
bit you know
we open ourselves and we become
vulnerable and we come on on shows like
this and we do it for many purposes I do
it oftentimes to help others and to help
myself I'm I'm a little selfish I'm
normal I'm Human coming on your show and
coming on some of the other shows that
I've done and you know what I've done a
host of shows I do it to
urge myself sometimes and then sometimes
get a chance to measure
where I'm at in life
and sometimes and I get this he's
stammering he's lying he's high no
sometimes my thoughts and my words
aren't connecting exactly at the same
exact time
so I mean you've heard people make fun
of not just myself but others on your
show they're stammering they're lying
and I'm like listen we're all human here
you know you have a wonderful audience
huge
and when people come on here and expose
themselves I mean you've got some pretty
crazy [__] takes a lot of
Courage it takes a lot I mean I've seen
listen my courage level is not near some
of these other guys you know and I I
just use pedals like you've interviewed
and incestuous people that you've
interviewed and and all the other stuff
that goes on that to me is like wow and
you know what you're doing them a
service even though and they get
attacked and it's because I read some of
the commentary shows really good
crucified
but the one thing about it is
people learn from those people that you
put up on here
and some of them some of the people that
they're helping and I hope I do the same
Mark some of the people that they're
helping are the people that are in their
closet somewhere
saying this is what I've done what do I
do how do I get through this and and and
maybe hey this is not a public service
Mark but maybe it is right maybe you're
saving someone else every time you've
turned that camera on
I I lost the job with the NYPD now
listen I'm gonna go back to that for a
minute the most illustrious Police
Department in the world right NYPD
movies
are made about it scripts are written
about them
um
cartoons over them headlines and every
tabloid in the world NYPD in fact look
you gotta tell you is the audience the
story if they missed it so a friend of
mine retired police officer who has PTSD
really bad
his brother died 911 lung disease
he was on the pile for eight months
himself vouchering livers like that's
what they were doing there picking up
the liver putting a tag on it like
that's what went on there and he was
that guy he was there for a long time
he doesn't like going across Bridges
anymore
nervous this is this happens to people
some I'm not never been aware of this in
my life but it happened there's many
people that won't cross the bridge
anyway so he asks me to go with him to
One Police Plaza now I've been in One
Police Plaza before by the way just so
you know so I go in with him
and they they Usher him in because he's
got his ID on him and he's there to get
a new police ID a re-up
so I go in with him and I put my
identification my license up because
they want to see who's coming and going
in their buildings
and they go I don't worry about it
you're with him go so I go upstairs
and sure enough he's getting he's
waiting to meet the sergeant to get his
new identification
it's set up nice they handled him nicely
in the meantime I looked to my left and
there's this Podium it says
retirement like congratulations you're
retired now if anybody knows me I'm a
little bit of a joker but I'm also a
self-deprecating [__] right and I
like to shine the light on what I gave
up in life and that's part of my what I
speak
so I woke up to this Podium and I tell
my buddy take a picture of me here I
said I never got my exit photo for you
know when you leave it's called an exit
photo you retire
I said and I want to take this photo and
I want to put it on my social media so
that I can show the people around me
that follow me specifically that this is
what I gave up
so he takes the picture of me I put it
up on my social media and don't you know
you get in trouble don't you know the
[__] hits the fan they're they're uh
calling me
a piece of [__] did you snort cocaine
off the railing on the way up to to take
the picture you should be taking it up
the ass I mean the things they said
about me you should have died of anal
cancer in prison oh [__] they said I'm
like and I get a one message from a
woman pretty detailed message and she
tells me why I'm a piece of [__]
and you know what I am I I believed her
I believe they're mock
because she made the point that there's
a lot of people that sacrificed their
whole life to get to that post and to
take that picture
and I I was about to take the picture
down because of what you said but she
called me a piece of [__]
now had sheep like any like but words
matter right words matter you know if
she had said to me Mike listen you did
your time you don't deserve to be
ostracized or publicly disgraced anymore
but that picture is a little bit out of
taste I you know I would have took it
right down Mark I would have but because
she chose to bash me along the way her
and then another 100 people on top of
her after after she initially bashed me
I refused to take it down I get a phone
call from the New York Post or one of
those dad were doing an article that you
were in headquarters taking a picture at
the retirement thing I said yeah what do
you want to know they go why were you
there I told him I said my friend was
PTSD you need an escort he wanted
someone to go he's retired New York City
Sergeant I think I did him a favor I
said yeah I took the picture I said but
but if you know my background I I'm
self-deprecating that this is what you
did your time I did my time this is what
I gave up I I'm I'm I'm flattered and
humbled by the fact that the people do
this and that I didn't get that chance
you're not still a criminal you're yeah
I'm clean
so
it it front page of the post now the
police commission is doing investigation
how did he get in the building I mean it
turned into a zoo The Daily Mail in the
UK is calling they're running a
three-page article in the united the
United Kingdom
fast forward six seven weeks later
the phone rings it's another newspaper
from New York they want to know we
understand you're and I don't even know
enough I don't know I know nothing mom I
know nothing you're banned from NY from
One Police Plaza I go excuse me
I'm banned from One Police Plaza they
said yes your picture was posted on the
wall in One PP at the entrance Zone that
you're banned
I said well isn't it a public building
have I banned from a public building
they said well you're banned
so they the post ran with the daily mail
ran with it again or the news they ran
with it so it became a circus
so it's like look it's it's like I wanna
I wanna pinch myself sometimes like
yeah I was a corrupt cop yeah they
called me the dirtiest cop ever but you
know we all know that that's not true I
didn't kill anybody by the grace of God
and and um
and the fact is that yeah I I did my
time Mark and people need to understand
that I got no pension I got no medical
coverage I came out broke and today I'm
borrowed this yet I borrowed the jacket
from somebody okay it's a nice jacket by
the way but I borrowed it so uh I'm of
little means today and that's okay I
keep my world small
I get treated out to some nice dinners
once in a while for a good conversation
and I do the best I can
what do you think's wrong with society
that that we're all so eager to
crucify
others
well you know and as everyone
understands you did your time you're now
a free man yeah you're no longer doing
the things so so these are the things
that come at me you should have known
better
right
I was a police officer I should have
known better expect it to be you're
expected to be above reproach
and you should have known better okay so
the problem that I've run into with that
statement is I should have known better
I did know better but you were raised
over here and you knew better too
you just didn't have a gun in badge but
you knew better your your parents told
you not to sell drugs not to skip school
you know not to have sex with the 17
year old girls when you're when you're
18. you know there's a lot of things
that happen in life but
they people forget that you're human
like I'm human I I'm fallible I'm
fallible this happens
um so
back to the original question from you
is why do people do this like why do
people expect more and they're
unforgiving of a guy like myself
and
sometimes I think and and I think it's
this right what's to say you point a
finger at me there's three or four
pointing back at
if I point one at you there's three or
four pointing back at me we're very very
eager to condemn yeah yeah they're eager
to condemn so usually that's those
people that are loud and condemning are
trying to distract from themselves but I
will say this Mark and this is the truth
rejecting their own guilt yes
as a flip side to that many people
that you would never expect are
forgiving
and that's the real Joy of this and
that's why sometimes coming on and
sharing your story
in forms like this I really found out
there's a lot a lot of people that are
willing to forgive
and that's the nice thing
and I think that and they're also less
likely to leave a comment on a social
media platform yes they are less like
but yeah plenty of people that watch
this plenty of people who don't make
comments yes I think it's one in ten
makes a comment maybe it's less than
that one in 100 but the ones that are
most likely to make a comment yeah are
typically the ones that are right
correct typically typically into haters
but you know what in this industry Mark
and you and I both of us to be honest
haters really make it go they do they do
make a big difference oh in terms of
views yes haters do I don't care about
that yeah you don't care about views I
know that but haters actually build an
audience because you know why people who
rally around the individual that's
exposing themselves that that happens
quite often like if one of the one of
the guys on your channel that throws
some hate at me you'll you'll get half a
dozen or a dozen people to say yeah well
you know what's what would you do if
you're in doubt situation those are my
favorite comments yes yeah that's and
somebody when somebody straightens out
somebody that just doesn't get it yes
correct yeah that that's very helpful
and I appreciate that about your
audience you have a great audience bro I
mean I'm not sure I'm so proud of how he
evolved yeah yes yes they're incredibly
involved it evolved yes yeah and and
it's intelligent it's quite the form
passionate
yeah so so forgiving so yeah just that's
what that and that's what really the
forgiving part is what I like because
anybody can get up here and get bashed
and people out in your audience can bash
well you know for what that's not an
easy thing to do you're exposing the
underbelly of society
and
the people that come on here are they
underbelly of society make it easy for
you if you're just looking to hate yeah
if you want to hey just go ahead you
know yeah so yeah but yeah you're taking
the easy way out I think there's a Carl
Young quote thinking is difficult which
is why people judge yeah it's quick
something like that it's done they cut
you right out rather than figuring it
out right and understanding maybe why
you did the things you did right and
forgiving because now you're you've done
your well you're just gonna hate
it's just it's simple here's how I look
at the simpletons from this perspective
I look at it like this if you want to
discuss something with someone don't
start off with hate
because now you shut the door
and you know our society is going
through a lot of turmoil right now you
know that and your audience knows who I
am maybe I've been I've been called out
excuses I've been called a Trumper and
all that other [__] and this mannerisms
are just like Trump they come they
attack me but what I am is I'm a true
blooded I love my country and I love my
people and I say my people I mean
anybody that will have a discussion with
me
that's how we make it all work mark
have a conversation
it's really interesting
yeah yeah no it's you're a very
interesting character because
you're you were called a racist at some
point another first like that was the
most ridiculous comment ever
like you said we don't answer that you
say the word Puerto Rican and all of a
sudden you're a racist like
that's a director I didn't know that I
thought that was
prideful thing Puerto Rican women women
are beautiful I mean what well you know
that don't get me in trouble on camera
so
so now your life goes where
yeah so Mark what's interesting is this
and and this has actually been going on
now for nine years since since the
documentary came out I've been owned by
different Studios I started out with
Sony then Columbia then there's one
other company I'm going to forget and
then Prime ended up owning me for a
while right now I'm actually in the
middle I'm negotiating with Prime and
I'm negotiating with somebody else to do
a movie a TV series and a movie
and we're trying to figure out how it's
going to go but that's that's positive
so the only thing is you know I still
got a day-to-day make bills you know uh
and these and these individuals in the
LA scene they don't think about that you
know they're like oh yeah we're gonna
get you a nice contract one day well I
gotta survive between now and then so
it's it's been a struggle for me Mark
and you know that but
I try to keep my world small as I might
have said earlier and
and I um I travel a lot people think I'm
rich because I travel a lot but you know
how I travel I travel on the cheap I'm
on Frontier you know I I'm fortunate I
have a place down in Florida that I own
so I get to stay there and then people
put me up on their couch and I'm willing
let me ask you a question that could be
controversial I don't want to put you in
on the spots but
I've asked people who have been through
terribly traumatic terrible things that
have happened to them and ask them like
you know what's your biggest regret or
what would you you know would you change
your life if you could have and they say
no I wouldn't change a thing and like
you you were shot in the face you lost
lost half your brain in your eye and you
still said right you you would take that
because it's made you who you are right
would you have changed what I mean I
understand you did something wrong you
understand that right but it made you
who you are today right
right would you have do you regret that
or do you wish you had hadn't done it or
how do you feel about that yeah see
that's
for me it's a little more difficult
because I know if I had done the right
thing
I would have the life that I that I want
today how's that sound
but I believe that it made me a better
person well I did if that's if that can
answer that more correctly because if I
had done the right things all along I
wouldn't be the good person that I am
today that's fact yeah that's a fact so
that's that's what I was saying earlier
yeah that's that's why this is how much
I moved to tears almost Mark that's why
I'm glad I went through what I went
through and you know what I have a
family of seven brothers and sisters so
total you know siblings and my mother
came to me after it was all over and she
said to me I'm glad it was you
and I looked at like what the [__]
wrong with me she goes because you could
handle it
like in other words if I had to have a
child that went through this I'm glad it
was you and I took that as a bandage of
Honor in my home right I mean what the
hell but yeah I I think that to
reiterate what we had just said I think
that it's important that I'm a better
person for what I went through because
if I had done the 20 and retired I got
my pension
first of all no one would really know me
right which is fine because I really
don't need the attention although part
of this industry you need to gather
intention right and you know that in the
in you have to have some attention
otherwise you don't exist
but for me I love helping people I
and so you need attention to help people
because if they don't know how to get to
you or where you are then now some
people are a little rude and intrusive
and and have expectations Beyond
and I know you know that I mean if you
walk down the street in L.A it's like
this everywhere you go for crisis not
that we're encouraging doing something
criminal in your life no so you can
become a better person no not at all
maybe you could how's this this is great
well I'm glad you brought that up how
about this how do we learn how to cut
through that and take someone
who inherently has the um desire so I'm
a teacher
really I'm a teacher but I never knew
that
and that sort of pisses me off in a way
you know like why didn't I know that I
was a teacher I wanted to communicate
with people well see that's what I think
we all are I think we're all teachers
we're all therapists we're all
everything that's you need to be
everything in order to be a well-rounded
person yeah yeah but teacher right I
mean that's like that's really what I I
so I am a teacher today right I'm
teaching people on a daily basis how to
do what I not do what I've done try to
be more like I am today not necessarily
don't copy me because I'm not perfect
but if you want to get away from
something and be more like somebody that
you and people look up to me I don't
know why but if they do and you want to
be a little bit more like me in a way so
I'll tell you a quick story I hate to do
this but I digress so I was in prison
now you got to realize when you're in
prison things slow down and when I'm in
prison I'm running an AA group in prison
and in comes this black gentleman little
light-skinned handsome fella educated
and I'm sitting in a room of 25 convicts
okay and he just fell into the door you
know he's a fresh piece of meat coming
in right but he's a well-spoken you know
he's a white collar black guy so a lot
of people gravitate to that in prison
people say want to know how and why and
what he's done but me I give him the
distance I don't jump on his you know
face and try to learn from him yet
because I've been around a while now
I'm speaking in an AAA meeting at the
end of the meeting after the third or
fourth meeting he attended he comes over
to me and he says uh
Mike yeah I forget his name
I just want to tell you something he
goes what's that he goes
the way you speak in front of this group
of people here
he says you're fabulous nothing but
compliments so I said to him why are you
telling me this
he says to me because I wish I could
speak like that in front of a group like
this
I'm looking at this guy who's in here
for white you know and listen if anybody
knows anything white car was big right
because if you know that they use their
brains to take money from some place or
one place or another all right they
didn't use their brood of their brawn
and um
so it it actually he who was
uncomfortable doing what I was doing
gave me a sense of confidence and that's
pretty cool like even in prison you can
learn quite a bit well I think everybody
knows that but the fact is you can learn
a positive way so here I am running an
AA group in prison thinking I'm just
doing my time getting these guys through
the required meetings and and and I'm
being built up by some guy on the side
and he doesn't know he's building me up
so it was really so there you go
Mike what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
well yeah no one's ever asked me that
question
the most important thing I've ever
learned in my life
love
that's great
perfect
the greatest answer ever
McDowell thank you so much
well that was deep you're amazing as
always
okay